monsieur le ministre le président de la
république m les élus d'ailleurs il n'a
cessé de le répéter hier lors du congrès
des maires de france
mais votre gouvernement a quand même la
fâcheuse habitude de s'immiscer dans les
finances locales
concernant la taxe d'habitation françois
baroin a eu raison de rappeler hier au
président de la république que vous avez
décidé de supprimer un impôt qui ne vous
appartient pas il faut que la
considération aille de pair avec le
respect alors de respect il en est
question quand votre gouvernement dépose
sur le projet de loi de finances pour
2020 un amendement prévoyant qu'une
partie des droits de mutation à titre
onéreux perçue par les départements
franciliens et la ville de paris sera
prélevée au profit de la société du
grand paris
excusez du peu 75 millions d'euros en
2020 puis 60 millions d'euros par an à
partir de 2021 pour financer tenez vous
bien les engagements de l'état inscrit
dans le contrat de plan etat-région
2020-2022 sur les transports coupons mon
département plus de 3 millions d'euros
alors même que l'essonne pâtit
d'infrastructures de transport surchargé
est vieillissante
non content d'avoir reporté la
construction de la ligne 18 qui devait
dynamiser le plateau de saclay des
yvelines jusqu en essonne où le charles
de gaulle express qui devait faciliter
l'accès au village olympique en
seine-saint-denis l'état nous ponctionne
a posteriori pour sa mauvaise gestion
je veux bien vous accordez vous n'êtes
pas les seuls responsables du passif de
la sgp
mais quand on exerce des compétences il
faut en assumer les responsabilités et
le financement aussi ma question est
simple sur le ministre quand ce
gouvernement va-t-il cesser de
dévitaliser les collectivités locales et
en particulier nos départements au
mépris des élus et des populations que
nous servons et cela vous n'avez compris
n'est pas qu'un problème franciliens